why is screenwriting hard it's not it's
not okay I don't think it's hard
anything's hard that you know you're
forcing anything's hard you're forcing
if you're fortunate it's hard it then
maybe is the career aspect of it hard so
maybe it's easy the screenwriting
process is easy oh yeah
the the navigating of a career is always
more challenging than doing the actual
thing you know like there are tons of
incredibly talented actors that are not
stars for one reason or another that has
nothing to do with how talented they are
as actors same thing with writers
directors musicians songwriters you know
the career trajectory is a completely
different skill set you know I mean
that's why it's so important to to
either have someone who can guide you
through it or figure out how to market
stuff so that it appeals to the people
you're trying to get it to but yeah like
you know I said earlier way easier to
write the script and pitch it that's
right they'll ask you for like a logline
that's like a few words that takes me
forever to figure out but you want a
hundred pages of a script done easy
gotcha now you want me to take those
hundred pages and put them in a sentence
why I got a hundred pages I think you
know so it's still just different skill
sets but I don't necessarily don't think
it's the only it's necessarily hard you
know it can be challenging can be
difficult there could be research
involved it's you know not
necessarily easy but I wouldn't
categorize it as hard unless you're
forcing it or there are forces impeding
on the creative flow necessary so were
there times where you had someone that
wanted to quote guide your career and
sometimes it's better to go in on alone
like yeah it's someone that saw things
in you they thought this would be great
let's work together on the trajectory of
your career hmm and maybe early on you
could kind of see maybe that wouldn't be
better just to be on your own yeah it's
like the manager told me I should change
the script make it a dude when they was
written about a woman it's like he's not
wrong not right he's not wrong it's just
a different it's a different you know
people get caught up in like right wrong
blame is that it's like there's stuff
that is and then there's stuff that
isn't like whatever perception you put
on it is your perception you know you
get way more I get way more accomplished
with that mindset then trying to figure
out right and wrong this and that and
then I like this I think this works
I think this proceeds in a manner that
would be entertaining to millions of
people what do you think I think it
should be like this this this this this
this okay
what do you think I kind of dig it I
think you can make some tweaks make it
even cooler
what are your tweaks those sound really
cool okay we should work yep that's all
I think it comes down to you know it's
it's it's if it's not a fit it's not a
fit it's like anything else it's like
friends it's like dating it's like a
marriage it's if you're constantly doing
this
maybe it's not a fit maybe it's not a
fit maybe there's a better way of
getting your work see her done you know
Tyler Perry was homeless trying to
figure it out
couldn't get anything cooking started
turning the scripts in the plays now
he's sitting on top of an empire
it's worth hundreds of millions of
dollars doing whatever he wants to do
I'm sure somebody told him well this is
dumb Tyler Perry you shouldn't do that
maybe they were right maybe you would
not happen quicker maybe they were wrong
it happened the way it was supposed to
you know I mean so well I just think
it's a I just think it's a matter of
perspective I just think the most
important thing is for you as a writer
to know who you are as a writer like you
have to know who you are what you do
because they don't you know I mean like
they may have ideas about what they
think it could be and if that links up
with what you are awesome but you gotta
know like you got to know where you want
to go what you want to do how you want
to do it the kind of thing you dig the
kind of thing you don't what you're good
at what's not good at because otherwise
you get stuck in this battle can you got
an agent or a manager or executive or
producer trying to get you to do
something that's not what you want to do
and it's no good so not just the writers
voice but what they want to do with
their career what kind of projects they
know there is it I I think yeah I think
a writer should understand their
identity as a writer doesn't mean you
can't branch out and do other things you
know what I mean it doesn't mean you
can't branch out and my
attack different genres and stuff but I
think you know you should have a very
clear understanding of who you are as a
writer just like you should have a very
person you know like you know people are
different and they have different
attributes and they have different value
systems and that's who they are
yeah you know for better or for worse
that's who they are
but they know who they are when they
know who they are I think a writer it's
the same way this is what I do you know
what I mean
you watch a Shonda Rhimes show you know
what you're getting and now even things
that she doesn't create but things that
she executive produce still feel like
the things she wrote because she knows
what she does as a write this is what I
do this is this is it Ryan Murphy who
runs the gamut from American Horror
Story to Glee but there's still a thread
in there that lets you know that's when
I Murphy that's what he does the late
Steven Bochco that's what he did you
know what I mean like there's there's a
there's a identity as a through-line
that comes from this is what I do Steven
J Cannell yeah all great show runners
that people know you know maybe they
don't know the title showrunner but you
know these impresarios and in film -
Martin Scorsese who ran the gamut from
you know Goodfellas to the age of
innocence still Martin Scorsese movie
you know knows knows who he is I think a
writer should too
you